daniel mingdon will make the start for
these daniel three stints in the big
leagues last year he was five and two
with the 483 era
so nolan renato as most of you know the
high school teammate of matt chapman
at el toro high school down in lake
forest in southern california
now the o2 pitch to arnotto
and it's a swing and a chopper toward
third to his old high school teammate
chapman spears it and throws it first
for the out good play a do or die play
well an opportunity here for daniel
murphy the pause at the belt throws and
it's swung on to miss those that buy him
fastball 90 and the inning is over
antonio cenzatzella will try to bounce
back after a very tough campaign last
year yes he was an 11-game winner he was
11 and 11 but his era
6.71 would be a great time for chris
davis to get his first knock of the
season one two curve ball popped up
boy what a good pitch call by
tony walters in short center field ryan
mcmahon's got it tony wolters who came
up with an rbi hit
in the game on sunday looking to do it
again here in his first at bat tonight
3-2 pitch swung on and popped up
playable on the infield it's going to be
chapman and simeon it's going to be
marcus is there and he makes the catch
and now get to the heart of the order
with the cleanup man nolan aronado no
balls and two strikes
nolan lifts this to left field and it
should be deep enough get behind it is
grossman here comes story down the lane
it'll be cut off
and moving up is blackman he tagged as
well and nolan behind in the cap gets it
done the rockies take a one-nothing lead
so a runner in scoring position for
daniel murphy
oh two basketball hit in the air to ride
easy chance out there for canna
and he's there to make the catch the
inning is over and now mark kenna
with a chance to do some damage
centitella's pitch swung on in the gap
left center field on the run is dahl and
he'll get there makes the catch tagging
from third and scoring without a throw
is loriano chris davis will step in
power hitting d.h there's the pitch
swing and a miss he got him on a high
fast ball
so sam hilliard to step in
curveball high in the air deep right
center field take a good look you won't
see it for long
sam hilliard is struck and the rockies
lead it three to one
jordan weems drafted as a catcher by the
red sox he's from columbus georgia
and he's on the mound ready to make his
major league debut a main that would
make simba jealous yes he'll get ready
to work against trevor story
a wide open stance here's the fish to
him on the inside corner rig him up
pretty good way to start his big league
career jordan williams with a strikeout
of trevor story looking on a fastball in
the inside corner
and daniel murphy will try and be the
guy to deliver
and on the ground through the right side
base hit blackman come on down four to
one colorado
and rymel tapia who's singled and scored
on the hilliard homer will
see what he can do and he hits it in the
air to
center field moving into position
is loriano he's got a great throwing arm
his throw to the plate the tag was
missed nolan didn't touch the plate but
came back and got it as austin allen
stood there and watched allen knew he
missed the tag
but didn't stay with the runner as nolan
is able to score to make it five to one
sam hilliard with a 399
foot home run is last time up now the
one-two pitch on the way swung on or
miss throws it by him i said
strikeout on an off-speed pitch but the
rockies get two more
and that'll bring up kenna and mark is
walking out of sac flight here's the 2-1
pitch and the ground ball back at third
r otto's got it and he bobbles it and
everybody's going to be safe huge break
for the a's and here's chris davis in a
big spot pitch to davis is grounded to
arnotto he's got this one to second for
one on the first for a double play
good job by nolan mcmahon and murphy
and the damage is minimal that'll bring
up tony walters
mcmahon away from second trevino will
come to the plate and tony rips it to
right fairball
inside the right field corner mcmahon
rounds third he will score
on his way and
holding at third is
rymel tapia the rockies make it six to
two on an rbi double by tony walters
still only one out with two men in
scoring position for the top of the
order david dahl
which is driven to right by dahl going
back is canna it is off the top of the
wall
into second base goes nope
yeah did he get into second he did get
into second david dahl had to wait for
the camera to show us for sure as
we watch it off a monitor he just missed
his first homer two more runs score and
the rockies have broken it open with a
three run eighth they lead it eight to
two charlie blackman
at the plate charlie hits it
to second
with the ball pinned around over to
olson at first one out that'll bring up
grossman
and robbie is one for three
runners at second and third in the pitch
by bard and it's a ground ball to second
of a score of the run but the rockies
want out the flip to first by mcmahon is
in time scoring is olson
canada third grossman's out 4-3 it's now
an 8-3 game and that'll bring up hinder
pinder sends it in the air
to right field charlie blackman coming
in fighting the wind a little bit he's
got it and that ends the inning daniel
murphy has an rbi
single in four tries swinging a miss the
ball gets away from allen however and
murphy is aboard see if sam hilliard can
pick him up sam a double and a two run
homer tonight
three and two
out of the stretch and here's the pitch
by wendelken and swung onto a mestos if
i'm a fastball in 93. two outs in the
ninth for
center fielder ramon lauriano
and this is to nolan
and that's your ball game what a
terrific complete performance
offensively and on the mound for the
rockies tonight